[Musique]
le stampede demeure un incontournable du
mois de juillet pour les touristes de
l'ouest canadien
chaque année le festival accueille plus
de 2 millions de visiteurs seulement
pour le défilé d'après les organisateurs
environ deux cent mille personnes sont
descendues dans les rues de calgary
preuve que la mauvaise température ne
les a pas effrayer les gens sont
chaleureux souria de bonne humeur
l'appui dérange personne c'est berner
une grande foule c'est très festif
beaucoup de musique la bouffe la bière
tout est beau la bassée c'est vraiment
de l'endroit pour s'amuser de 104 1000
personnes qui prennent part cette année
à ce grand défilé parmi cela il ya 19
ans en entrant de chars allégoriques et
environ 200 chevaux
ce sont beaucoup de touristes et de
calgariens qui sont arrivés tôt ce matin
pour certains c'était à 4h30 pour
réserver des places alors il les
attendait patiemment méchant que ça
s'intéressent 1 2
devoir tout l'héritage que de centaines
d'années et comme la tradition le veut
le yarou au crédit stampede étaient à
l'honneur vendredi
plusieurs politiciens étaient du convoi
à commencer par naheed nenshi le maire
de calgary et des conseillers municipaux
à mardi de sa ministre fédéral des
ressources naturelles portait aussi
fièrement le chapeau de cow boy comme le
premier ministre de l'alberta son cheval
nommé texas jason kenny qui a d'ailleurs
invité ses homologues à se joindre à lui
pour les festivités
la semaine prochaine j'ai invité
plusieurs premiers ministres venir nous
visiter pendant le chantier
les premiers ministres des provinces et
l'inde il y aura un entretien ici à
calgary
le système italien
tout septembre 1912 cette année
et le 107e mais c'est ce qu'il a un
souci les dix jours de fête en métropole
ici une charte du moulin et du canada
calgary
[Musique]